now how is our money now like currently
like how is
our the dollar bills that we buy stuff
with how is that
related or tied at all to gold well it's
not
so at all so the
and the path to that is pretty but
wasn't it supposed to be originally
it was originally okay so
back in the i guess to go back to what
we were kind of talking about with like
the goldsmiths and whatnot
the the origins of banking as we know it
today started with
you know you'd have gold and you'd want
to own gold to
buy things but you'd have to store it
and keep it safe
and sometimes that was a problem and so
what they would do is they the
goldsmiths who you know would make
things out of gold like
jewelry and stuff they would already it
would have like 24 7 armed guards or
something at their place
and a vault or something to keep them
safe so people would say okay you know
what
this guy is really good at keeping gold
safe so i'm gonna see if he'll keep my
gold safe for me
and then and and for a fee and
and the goldsmiths are like yeah this
sounds like a great idea i already have
the vault
it's got plenty of room so i'll i'll
just add yours to it yeah you pay me a
fee
and what they would get in return would
be like a receipt basically that says
hey
you own this much gold uh at my volt
and and you can come in and claim it
anytime like a monetary note
yeah so um over time
what ended up happening is those notes
instead of somebody saying oh i really
want this
let me run down to to the goldsmith
get my goal and i'll be back and i'll
pay you
what sort of ended up happening over a
period of time is people would
they would allow you to sign your rights
to the gold away
it's kind of like the precursor of what
we'd know as like a checkbook today
you could sign the note endorse the note
and say okay i'm endorsing this over to
this guy and so if he comes
to you and wants gold he can get it
so then you pay him with the note
instead of the gold you pay
you pay whoever you're buying uh
whatever you buy back then
uh a horse a horse yeah some
some armor a sword i don't know
so uh you do that and um and then he
could go reclaim it and then eventually
what happened is they were just bearer
notes
meaning whoever's holding this uh they
don't need to sign anything they just
show up and they present it and they can
they can they can redeem it and so these
started to circulate
throughout the economy and there'd be
different goldsmiths who'd have
different notes but
basically they started they acted as
money because they were redeemable for
for gold but they were more portable and
and easier to store
because they're just paper so the
goldsmiths kind of figured out
that only you know there's only you know
once they this
became like a big part of their business
only like
15 or 10 of
their patrons would come in on any given
week or month
to withdraw their gold so they had all
this gold that just kind of sat there
why not make money with it while it's
sitting there
and um so at first it started where they
would have an agreement with
the gold holder like if somebody had a
lot of gold there they say hey how about
we loan this gold out and we can earn
interest
and then we'll split the interest you
know
and the guy would say yeah that sounds
great and so they do that
and um but then eventually the banksters
even you know especially for like small
depositors
they would they would cut out that
portion of it they would just say okay
you can leave it here and maybe that
maybe they don't have a fee for you
leaving it there maybe they'll do it for
free but
they're gonna be loaning it out and
making interest on it so that's how
so they started in addition to their
storage fees they were maybe in
in place of their storage fees they'd
start um
loaning the gold out or loaning the
notes out for the goal well
or were they they weren't learning the
actual so so no they would loan notes
for the gold right right
so they leave the gold safe in the vault
and they do shoot notes because the
notes are circulating like currency
so that allowed them to make money on
the the reserves and their vaults
what then came next was a pretty
brilliant idea which is hey you know
again nobody comes in for all this at
once
and who's to really know uh if we
put more notes out there than we
actually have gold in our vaults
so let's say if they had 100 ounces of
gold in their vaults
maybe they'd give a loan and instead of
you know so then they'd say they have 85
of their gold they're leaving they're
leaving so 85
ounces of gold they're leaving for loans
so say if they've already loaned out
those 85
uh ounces of gold or the paper backing
it but somebody comes to them and they
still
they want a loan too they say well you
know what nobody's gonna notice if
there's 10 more ounces
of gold paper you know receipts floating
out there
um so i'm going to loan this guy these
receipts and he'll pay me back interest
and so that would be that would that's
called fractional reserve banking
so that the fractional reservation so
basically
the amount of uh notes you have out
there
so so liabilities right the amount of
notes you have to repay
outweighs what you actually have in the
bank okay
as long as everybody doesn't show up at
once
it's not a problem and you can make
money uh
on on the notes that have nothing back
in them
and so this kind of became
a pretty addictive sort of drug because
you literally you can literally just
make money
out of nothing you make interest on
holdings you don't even have
so it's at first it started you're using
other people's money to make money
right other people's deposits to make
money which was great
but then it just kind of went to this
next level where you can
based on your reputation you can and
your notes circulating in the economy
you can just
push them out there and people will
still
circulate them and so you know bankers
could have
had and have in the past inflated you
know there to double or
triple the amount of notes they'd have
on based on
the gold they would have in the bank
yeah and what would happen is they
then you'd get what's called bank runs
which people may have heard of
bank runs bank runs so basically if the
word gets out
that there's not that they have that
they're a
dishonest banker or whatever and they've
put out way more notes
way more paper than they have backing it
what are people gonna do
they're gonna go and they're gonna be
like well i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna get left holding the bag
if they don't have the gold i'm gonna go
get mine
right now and they show up and they
they want the gold and and then they and
then then eventually
they run out and then you still have a
line out the door
of people with the receipts and they
collapse and fail right
right which is kind of a good thing
because it was a
sort of free market way to keep these
guys from
going crazy with this whole scheme so so
there's always this threat of bank runs
what we have now
is like that system on
crazy steroids like uh like like bigger
than arnold was at his peak
you know um so the federal reserve you
know
during the history united states um like
when the united states was formed as the
articles of confederation so it was just
like separate states in like this loose
confederation
and it was like that for about 10 years
after the revolutionary war
so each state kind of
you know the history of how governments
learn to
to issue paper currency and stuff is a
little convoluted too but
the sort of moral of the story is that
the states there was hyperinflation
in a lot of the states because when and
we can talk about that
a little bit later inflation and how it
affects us
but what they kind of learned the
founders learned
through experience was that um
really this whole government printing
money thing didn't really work that well
and so in the u.s constitution it's
actually
in there that only gold and silver shall
be money in the united states of america
[Music]
and so that was that was the case for
for a while we had
two central banks one was called i think
the bank of the united states
it was founded in like 1800 or something
like that
and then it its charter ran out and then
andrew jackson
there was a second bank in the united
states that was chartered as well
and andrew jackson
quashed that one it's something he's
kind of famous for it's kind of a crazy
story
and then we didn't really have a central
bank
until 1913 and actually i just went to a
conference on jekyll island last week
which is an island off the coast of
georgia it's a little barrier island
it's i think actually the smallest one
it used to be a retreat that jp morgan
owned
in the 1800s it was the jackal island
club and there's this book that
everybody should read
uh by a guy named george griffin called
the creature from jekyll island
and it's basically like the
comprehensive history of the founding of
our federal reserve
and it was founded uh the reason it's
called the creature from jekyll island
is that it was um
like they they got together a cabal of
guys some senators and some big bankers
got together
on jekyll island in 1910 and they
basically drafted what would become the
federal reserve act that created the
federal reserve bank
which is wow or the fed we know it is
the fed
so that's why you guys did your
conference there yeah so
there was a conflict there actually yeah
there was a conference there over the
weekend it's kind of
um you know a fun thing to yeah go and
and there
if you go to the jackal island club
there's a federal reserve room and
there's a plaque that says in this room
the federal reserve was you know drafted
or talked about
it at the time though it was a big
secret because they didn't want anybody
to know
who was getting together and why and
where
because it would have gotten people
suspicious but
bottom line is uh with the creation of
the federal reserve
it allowed it allowed the
with any central bank england pretty
much invented central banking
they had the bank of england it was like
the first central bank um
and and the federal reserve is pretty
much a copycat of that and what it
allows the government to do
is um
this whole fractional reserve system so
you know the government has a certain
amount of money
and that the federal reserve will hold
that money like the gold literally gold
um there's literally gold in the federal
reserve well there's a debate about that
too
but there definitely has been in the
past so
you know fort knox is is is where the
treasury holds supposedly holds a lot of
its gold and then also the federal
reserve bank of new york i think has a
big vault
supposed to be a lot of gold in there
too so
um so you have this this gold before
1913 only gold and silver was
money in the united states um so
we had silver coins so the quarter the
nickel of the dime
well not the nickel the nickels made of
nickel but the the so the the nickel
sorry the the dime and the quarter the
half dollar the dollar
were all silver coins pure silver well
like a 90 silver i believe and then
um we had uh
what was called the morgan dollars which
were these these big uh
gold um they're big gold pieces
and these actually circulated as money
we also had banknotes that circulated
and
and stuff like that too before the
federal reserve but
when the federal reserve was founded
what we had is this this ability of the
government
to
the way the government funds itself is
with taxes you know up to that point
and debt so the government issues bonds
and i'm sorry i know this is like like
i'm like i feel like this is like the
feeding with the water hose here
no no it's okay no it's looking over
skipping over like so much stuff no
that's good
but the government makes money uh raises
money with bonds which is basically debt
okay so people buy the bonds like you
know during the war you've heard about
like world war ii buy your war bonds to
help pay for the war and stuff like that
okay um and so they'd sell them to
private entities basically
and so people would buy the bonds and
they would yield returns that was the
way the government could raise money for
projects
okay well what the federal reserve can
do is
they can buy bonds as well
so they're like a bank but they're
chartered by the the charter by the
congress actually so they're like a uh
like a hybrid sort of organization so
it's a private bank but it's
chartered by congress so they have
special privileges
and they can buy the government's debt
and this is kind of getting to how how
it works today but when they buy the
government's debt
they they issue the government dollars
for that debt right
but they literally just print the money
for that debt to the government they so
they say okay thank you government for
oh we'll buy a billion dollars in
treasury bonds for me sure
and they'll send the u.s treasury a
billion us dollars
a billion federal reserve notes they're
called federal reserve
those federal reserve notes are they
literally just print them
well these days they don't even print
them they just it's just like a data
entry
so um
so the kind of the brass tax is that
they that
when the government needs money so let's
just use like
you want to know about today's money um
when the government needs money for
stimulus checks
right okay for people right they don't
say okay how much taxes do we raise this
year
you know can we can we afford this how
much money did they spend on this on the
stimulus checks this year something in
the trillions yeah well it's like yeah
it's like
a trillion or two trillion dollars right
so
when um
when they do that they don't sit there
and say okay how can you know how many
let's take from
we're gonna we can't afford this we're
gonna take from this
you know entity we're gonna cut the fda
budget here we're gonna
we gotta make this happen now they don't
do any of that they don't look at the
tax revenues they don't care
all they do is they go to the federal
reserve and they say hey we need two
trillion dollars
okay and the federal reserve says okay
well
start printing your treasury bills you
know your bonds
that we're going gonna buy and print two
trillion of them we'll buy two trillion
dollars worth of bonds
and then we'll give you two trillion
dollars and
it's literally just comes out of so now
the government just owns
owes them two trillion dollars yes
in the future and they pay interest on
that too to the federal reserve
um so that's uh
so basically uh there really is and ever
since 1971 i can talk about that in a
second
there is no gold backing for the us
dollar at all okay and story it's not
backed by anything it's bad
it's backed by the faith and
the military essentially the united
states
foreign